my
enjoyment lies 100 in helping others
get that sort of deep understanding of
their why or their purpose or their path
[Music]
i mean the biggest frustration that many
athletes that come to me
have is
that i keep telling them it will appear
for you do not try to force it you know
you can't manipulate your life path
and they don't want to hear that and it
takes a few years and then they'll come
back and go you know what you're sort of
right back then i'm ready to take that
journey now right
but but my power meter says this chris
and i needed to say this
yes but the only way it's going to say
that is if you let go
and let you know it's like we know from
swimming you know it's like whenever
we're too tight um on i might today this
set is going to be so intense like you
try to get yourself mentally ready for
it and then you get there and you're
three or four repeats in and you're
nervous and you're not swimming well and
your walls are awful and you're just
like chopping through the water and then
it's like what am i making such a big
deal out of this and then
slowly you return into what you're
capable of
and
that's the hardest part that dichotomy
yeah caring enough that for the for the
result and the outcome but also letting
go enough for letting the result and
outcome to happen for you
the eckhart tolle yeah that's literally
my favorite you know
right now i'm living in a space of of
possibilities on both sides of
everything like both things can be true
and you know i don't um
work with
older athletes like you do but the
younger generation these teenagers it's
the same thing it's like this i don't
want to let go of that control because
if i let go of that control then
i'm gonna fail i have you know then then
my confidence will will you know go down
the drain all these other things that
people just hold on so tightly to and to
let go
is such a physical
um experience too that you have to
experience through your body which i'm a
big fan of just that whole conversation
but i think we try to use our minds to
to wrap around that to where it's like
i'm just going to let go with my mind
and then yes we can let go with our
minds but then we're just our bodies are
still tense and our minds are trying to
let go and conceptualize this thing that
we haven't actually experienced through
our whole physical being which i think
quarantine has allowed people to tap in
to themselves in a different way because
they don't have that physical outlet in
the same way
um so they have to release physically
through other modalities right you know
i think that that's a
uh an appropriate kind of place to segue
into something you were talking about in
your podcast the other day which is this
idea well two ideas the first being
um
uh to think about not just working out
but working in which is kind of what
we've already been talking about but
also
this idea of of showing up is not enough
like where is the intentionality that
you're bringing to what it is that
you're doing and of course this is
something that's applicable to
any athlete how they're approaching
their training regimen but in life to
whatever it is that we're doing
particularly now where everything has
been upended and it's causing confusion
and anxiety and we're all kind of asking
ourselves questions about like what why
am i doing this like you know we're all
being
re-evaluated yeah we're all everybody's
re-evaluating in their own way right now
yeah but that's part of what i go into
there and that is you know once you have
your purpose and your clarity you can
show up with intention um because you're
not questioning the goals you're not
questioning the path now you can focus
all your attention onto executing the
next workout the next day at work this
project to the best of your ability
because you're not wondering well why am
i you don't want to be asking why am i
doing this that takes everything that
you have in that workout or in that
project or that vacation with your
family you show up with intention too
like if you start wondering why am i
here you're not going to have a good
vacation you're not going to have a good
workout you're not going to have a good
workout work outcome and so the big
thing there is
once you've have the bigger picture the
purpose and once you have the clarity
which is what i call the coaching the
path the manual the sort of map
then you can execute the workout
properly you can execute your training
without wondering why am i doing this
how is this going to help me is this
keeping me on my path towards my desired
outcome
and is this what the coach and i
discussed it's all been laid out already
and we know that from swimming we're
just so ingrained in this that we do of
well of course these 400 ims are helping
me swim my 400 i am better of course
this set of 200s with the middle hundred
fly is helping me smooth my 400 i am
better but in the endurance training
world or in just in the work world if
you don't know where you're heading and
why you're doing it the quality of your
work is always going to be
limited because you're just constantly
wasting cognitive energy cognitive load
as they call it on other things in order
to make it more intentional and clear
for you once you have that out you can
hit flow you can you're right in the
moment because you're not worried about
all the other things because they've
been clarified for you the scaffolding
is set
and what i mean by that is when we start
training especially as masters athletes
not when we're younger but as
the training is a scaffolding what
happens inside that scaffolding is
unique to everybody
i might be doing a lot of
mental work other people might be doing
physical work other people are doing
spiritual work the training is the
placeholder
and what's being rebuilt in that
building
is it a complete rebuild is it some sort
of remodeling
right but
this the training sets up the
opportunity every day to spend time with
yourself and you might not want to go in
that day you might just sort of you know
do a little paint job
but other days you're like
knocking down walls and you are doing
some serious work inside and the tears
come or the aha moment comes and you're
like wow i hadn't realized how badly i'm
avoiding or you know you're listening to
a podcast and something you say for
example just trigger something boom
pause the podcast keep rolling and just
work with that sentence or with that
emotion that just came up but again i
think it's important that that curiosity
sets up the training the scaffolding so
that you have an opportunity every day
or every few days if you're not training
every day to sort of
do that working in and working out
[Music]
you